ein ordner
eine richtige kann man sie einfach
automatisch alles geld was ich gekauft
habe
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut meine
haare die sind sehr sehr lange ich mein
deutschland ich war beim friseur
wir sind nämlich gerade in new york das
hab ich muss selber kurz dem thema ja ja
ja also wir sind mitten in new york in
manhattan
das ist das neue world trade center
da standen wir die anderen world trade
center und ja wir sind hier praktisch im
juli urlaub also wir besichtigen ein
bisschen new york für sechs tage knapp
eine woche und dieses video entsteht
spontan das habe ich nicht geplant ich
war nämlich wie man wir sind
vorangekommen
und dann habe ich nach einem supermarkt
gesucht und er hat mir direkt neben uns
amazon co angezeigt ich habe davon schon
mal gehört das ist das in amerika gibt
es gibt es wohl in new york und noch in
noch auf jeden fall nur hier und in noch
ganz wenigen anderen städten und ich
meine das muss ich ja mal austesten und
dann dazu ein video machen weil in
deutschland gibt es das ja nicht da geht
es um eine ganz neue art von einkaufen
wir waren schon drei mal in diesem leben
drin damit man bisher mitgefilmt also
ich habe schon so viel gefilmt und ich
war schon so beeindruckt von allem weil
das ist wirklich krass und ich kann bis
jetzt kann ich noch nicht nach ganz
nachvollziehen wie das funktioniert weil
ich erkläre ich mal kurz bevor ihr die
aufnahmen sieht das konzept davon
es geht eigentlich nur darum dass die
ende laden rein geht euch praktisch mit
eurem amazon konto dass ihr vorher mit
in der app verknüpft haben muss an
meldet dass ihr da seid also es geht
alles direkt über amazon konto dann
könnt ihr euch nehmen was ihr wollt und
geht einfach wieder raus und kameras die
halter face kennen irgendwelche gewichts
sensoren die checken was wurde genommen
was nicht erstellen so eine art
algorithmus der dann die produkte dir
zuordnet und wenn du den laden verlässt
diese auf dein konto schreibt und die
musste dann halt einfach automatisch
bezahlen so also ganz verrückt ich weiß
immer noch nicht wie es ganz
funktioniert ich muss mir gleich immer
noch ein paar videos dazu anschauen ich
geh jetzt auf jeden fall erst mal
frühstück holen vielleicht bei amazon co
ganz lustigen neben einer visa karte ist
irgendwie gesperrt worden und ich habe
gerade keine andere möglichkeit an
lebensmittel zu kommen aus wir haben als
sohn mit diesem amazon konnte was ich
habe oder mit maries karten also wegen
jetzt erstmal los und sehen uns dann so
läuft das hier ist übrigens unsere
hotels so sieht das aus ziemlich klein
aber fein also wohl unser zimmer ist
eigentlich vor den ordnungen und wir
sind in der neunten etage ich war jetzt
erst mal runter nächster halt
aufgefallen ich habe mein handy
vergessen das heißt ich kann gar nicht
in den amazon store gehen oder amazon
store
wir gehen jetzt zu dunkin donuts und ich
zeige euch jetzt hier die aufnahmen die
wir gestern und vorgestern gemacht haben
viel spaß und seit nicht zu sehr
beeindrucken
gibt es öfter in amerika weißt du was
die kinder abholen
und wieder was wir nicht
es geht über amazon direkt zu mir zurück
also wird es mit einem amazon konto mit
dem papa alles auch gibbs nacken
ja oder nein
[Musik]
eigentlich
ja und jetzt muss das war bis jetzt ist
das amerikanische süßigkeiten testen
bitte können wir die bitte um mir die
haben die folgen abonnieren
also so viel auswahl haben die jetzt
aber nicht
pitschi wasser das muss mit dem 149
mit
aber hier ist viel wasser günstiger als
anderes wasser
komme dass man mit dem brauchen wasser
oder haben ja auch ein hotel wasser
nehmen gebe mein papa
bosse tipps
ja ja
mein akku ist fast lernen
aber hier gibt es diese hand kaufen
musste in der werbung sind
ja wo karl kamera lokal 8 dollar 49 lang
aber nicht so die nehme ich allein schon
mit weil da aber zur weltausstellung das
in deutschland einen kleinen unternehmen
darüber reingehen sie seien auf jeden
fall ein
salat heute abend noch aus
oder was wird sich heute abend noch
haben
das sind diese bleibt aber ich bin ich
hier richtig das sind die sachen
kaugummis oder
also es gibt auch ein paar sonst immer
in der werbung
heute guck mal das ist schon alles dass
ich so wenigstens 50 quadratmeter große
halle und bisher mehr vielleicht
die haben wir nur so eigentlich wie ein
kiosk
denn legen wir die noch mit comedy nehme
ich auch mit geht er auf meinen kopf die
nada
warum ist ja überall hier ist fleisch
amazon kämen schneller
ich will einfach nur immer das gut da
kann man sich selber was machen
ja man das nehmen wir noch nie
und
ende
[Musik]
ok
allerdings seien mit kameras haben die
einfach automatisch alles geld was ich
gekauft habe
man muss nichts machen wir können alles
nehmen und wieder rausreden
das ist und letztlich eine e mail was
bestimmt dass in fünf jahren wieder auf
leute was geht ab ich weiß es bisher bin
ich hier auf der anderen seite ist
einfach ein anderes ermessen gau ist
dieses ganze gebäude vielleicht einmal
ein alter da will ich eigentlich auch
noch ein leute da gehe ich gleich auch
noch einen neuen lieblingsladen lösen
ist im anderen leben entdeckt haben und
ja gleich filme die herauskommen
ich darf nicht mit rein leute wir sind
hier gerade wieder einem anderen amazon
co man kann hier sogar dann direkt seine
sache essen
das ist eigentlich auch meist oder egal
was man gekauft hat
dann brauche ich nur noch mal kurz sagen
also es ist ein ganz anderes konzept
[Musik]
lebt
heute und an der decke sind überall so
kameras die das ganze was
warum machst du eigentlich einander gut
drauf bist jetzt angeln okay leute
mittlerweile wieder zu dem zimmer hier
die wollte ich eben dies noch zeigen
das sind pringles pizza chips gibt es
hier auch in deutschland ich bin mir
nicht sicher ich glaube nicht aber
könnte schon soll schmecken sehr gut
möchte ich jetzt gar nicht erst mal
morgens habe ich schnell die kamera mal
hierhin ich wollte euch der mich noch
mal folgendes zeigen und auch ein
kleines resümee abhalten sorry dass das
alles so unprofessionell wirkt ich habe
einfach nicht die mittel aber nur diese
kleine block m
auf jeden fall was ich mich die ganze
zeit frage selbst wenn das mein gesicht
scannt und praktisch dann überall zu
ortet ich bin ja in den ersten laden mit
marie zusammen reingegangen und das hat
ja trotzdem geklappt marie konnte ja
auch sachen in den beutel legen das
heißt er muss ja praktisch unsere beiden
gesichter auf die karte gescannt haben
ich weiß nicht wie überfordert wenn ihr
das wissen schreibt das geld in die
kommentare ich habe jetzt so einen
artikel dazu gefunden wie das wohl
funktioniert weil von amazon gibt es
keine offizielle meldung dazu wie die
technologie dahinter aussieht warum weiß
ich nicht ja wahrscheinlich damit die
einzigen sachkenner amazon selbst
begnügt sich mit nebulösen schlagworten
spricht von computer vision sensor
fusion and deep learning und lässt
lediglich durchblicken dass man
technologien einsetzen wie man sie von
selbst fahren autos canon kameras und
eine kombination unterschiedlicher
sensoren füttern also einen lernenden
algorithmus so wie es am anfang auch
erklärt hat der erkennen soll welche
produkte kunden aus dem regal nehmen
oder wieder zurückstellen amazon dürfte
dabei auf eine technik bauen die ähnlich
der gesichtserkennung gegenstände aus
unterschiedlichen winkeln erkennt und
über modelle wie wir sie von rfid kennen
die jeweilige position von kunden und
produkte bestimmen
zudem können sensoren zum einsatz kommen
die das gewicht der produkte im regal
oder gar das gewicht oder die größe des
kunden erkennen alter die haben mich
gebogen oder was also wirklich ganz
verrückt das muss ich ja noch einen
blenden die haben ja ein beispiel
angeführt passt auf der kunde greift
sich eine rote flasche aus dem regal die
kameras erkennen eine rote flasche und
registrieren dass der kunde das produkt
behält die kameras erkennen aber nicht
genau das produkt weil ein anderer kunde
die sicht verdeckt das habe ich mich
auch gefragt obwohl wirklich an der
decke über kameras
also eigentlich musst du immer die
passende sicht auf den kunden finden in
jedem der kameraeinstellung dann wird
gesehen wo der kunde kauft erstens
regelmäßig ketchup der ketchup steht
normalerweise genau an dieser stelle das
system führt tschopp zum warenkorb hinzu
das heißt man wird praktisch also man
gibt noch mehr zu ackern amazon und die
wissen halt genau was man kauft und was
nicht also lebensmittel und alles einig
ich weiß nicht was ich dazu sagen soll
ihr könnt gerne in die kommentare
schreiben
meiner meinung nach wirklich fast
verrückt ich sehe das so dass es
wirklich vereinfachtes einkaufen ist man
geht halt nur noch mehr daten preis ob
das sein muss weiß ich nicht aber es hat
mir sehr viel spaß gemacht das zu testen
und ich werde es auch in den restlichen
vier tagen die wir haben noch weiter
nutzen das angebot also leute danke fürs
zuschauen dass es auch nach oben da wir
sehen uns übermorgen wahrscheinlich hier
wieder checkt auf meinen neuen kanal
alex v kommt jeden tag um 13 30 video
ist jetzt viel eingeblendet abonniert
den job instagram alexy ich poste ich
ich brauche jeden tag aus new york ein
foto app instagram